Here's one way to code the answer. We still compute the diffuse component, but
no longer take a maximum value, since we're going to compare it to uBorder. The
comparison here then changes the diffuse value so it gives a cartoony effect.
Here's a more compact solution, using a conditional operator instead of a
full-blown if, then, else statement. This critical angle rule is entirely
arbitrary of course. You could even try more elaborate rules. For example, this
code gives three levels of illumination. It gives an image with a different
feel, a bit more depth and a little less cartoony. This type of effect was
almost impossible with the old fixed function pipeline. With shaders it's easy
to experiment with different illumination models.